my name is krista
and i am a professor at the university
of california in irvine
i am also a developer of an open source
project i
one of my largest projects is a an open
source version of second life
so we reverse engineered second life and
we did the whole server side
from scratch um and what i'm going to
talk to you today is not about that
but it's about exercises in programming
style in particular
and so i'm wearing both of my hats as a
professor and as a developer
one thing that i realized in teaching
undergraduate students
is that you know we teach them a lot of
stuff
teach them how to use the language
specific languages always a
very big uh discussions in undergraduate
curriculum about what's the right
language to teach in indirect
introductory programming classes
um but you know i realized that we
actually don't really have the time
um to or or the framework to teach them
about something that i actually think
it's
very important at some point when they
mature a little bit more which is the
styles of programming the different ways
that people think
about approaching the computational
tasks that they that they have to do
and this is really difficult to teach
right
one thing is to teach java or closure or
you name it haskell or something it's
very it's there
you know very easy to teach um another
thing is to teach about
uh different ways of thinking about the
problems
and so um different ways of expressing
yourself in a way and and in in any way
that as i'm a
developer in a very large uh team with
lots of different people contributing to
the to the source code
you that the issue of style kind of hits
you in the face i mean
different people have completely
different ways of approaching the
problem where you go patch
some bug and you see you don't even know
no need to read through the commits to
find out who was the person who wrote
that code
you just know just by looking at the
code right so there's this
issue of style how do you approach how
do you write what you want to
express so um you know in art
people have been knowing this for ever
right there's all these styles of art
there's in in
painting for example there's modernism
impressionism
abstract expressionism realizing cubism
surrealism
photorealism or without just more of the
recent ones
so lots of them also way back then
um so what what what is this so
it's not you know for us we're not
experts in painting at least me
i look at this and say yeah it's just
kind of they're different
there's different flavor to them but
when you go to art school they actually
learn these things they they learn what
is it what techniques what
constraints do you apply to produce a
painting in impressionist style
right or in in realist style there's
rules
there's constraints okay and if you
apply those rules you end up with
something that looks like that or like
that or like that
and the way that they teach that is well
do you study the masters
okay you read some books the people who
make analysis of how
what's behind these styles and you know
sort of
bullet points you do this you do that
you don't do this you don't do that
that's it those are the sort of
codification of these different styles
and then what you want to paint is up to
yourself it's about how you
you know with the message that you want
to tell to everybody that's up to you
to you to figure out but the styles are
constraints
um so then if you are you know you can
end up with something like this if you
just want to go down to the point sorry
what happened here if you want to go
down to the point you just
you know different many different ways
of painting a
what happened here
many different ways of painting your
face i guess the sliders just won't that
does not want to stick
so i'll just i'll just go on it just
doesn't want to show itself to you
so thinking about programming styles uh
first thing that i went
went to look up in wikipedia right you
go wake up wikipedia as the first source
of information about
everything so i looked at the
programming style what wikipedia has
about programming style and now it just
i was just shaking my head thank god
that they have that big
you know mop over there warning readers
that um
this is really not a very good article
and so if you if you read through it
the first sentence is promising okay
programming style is a set of rules or
guidelines
good great and then it goes all goes
down the hill from there
uh the the second sentence doesn't even
make sense and i'll let you read just
for a second just read it
try to make sense out of this sentence
it's like what um
okay so basically if you read the rest
of the and it's a long page if you read
you you figure out that whoever wrote
this is is basically
saying that the programming style has to
do with appearance right it's aesthetics
you know spaces indentation
capitalization stuff like that um
i mean it's too bad that they didn't
even read you know
one of the works that that they're
actually referring to which is a
book that was written in the 70s by
carnegie uh the elements of programming
style if they had read this book they
would figure out that there's a lot more
to style than just indentation
um so and the other ironic thing is that
in this
big warning up there um it says well
this article is written like a personal
reflection
and then says please help improve it by
rewriting it in an encyclopedic style
okay so just just because oh man
just because you write a wikipedia page
and it looks like a wikipedia page it's
not an encyclopedic article
right to have encyclopedic style you
actually have to be careful about
references about backing up what you're
saying and all that stuff that's what
makes this equapedic style
okay this slide also doesn't want to
stick so let me go back to the next
programming style so what are
programming styles
there are ways of expressing the
computational tasks that we want to do
the interesting thing about programming
styles that i found that i find out and
probably also
some of you noticed that they exist in
all scales so they exist from the
small micro scale writing your little
lines of code
to designing systems you know big large
systems and
the interesting thing is that the styles
that you apply at the micro scale many
times
actually also apply to the system's
design level okay
in fact it's not by accident that people
who are
students who are very good in
programming languages end up also being
very good in designing large systems
because some of those thousands of those
concepts tend to just recur at different
scales they are
they just are sort of natural concepts
to apply
um and so another thing is that they are
end up being codified in programming
languages right so what happens then is
that people
throughout all these 70 years of
computer programming
have thought about ways of approaching
computational tasks and some of them
they just like it so much
you know this i really like this style
let me make a syntax for it okay
or let me make just this is it i'm going
to design my programming language
around this programming style because
this is really good okay they did
it get frozen in programming languages
many ways and so
this is the thing that's hard to teach
it just with each style because then
people get stuck with these programming
languages
they don't realize that actually
something even below that
which is ways of approaching the
problems and it's actually independent
from the programming language that you
use
so why are styles important
because there are many and you should
you should celebrate oh man
okay uh you should celebrate diversity
let me see if this works
if this doesn't want to to show itself
i'm
going to try to maybe just do this
okay um they are they provide
common vocabularies when you are
developing a large system with with lots
of different people
um they are basic frames of resonance
and of course some styles are better
than others
we know that but you know it depends on
many things it depends on your objective
function it depends on what you want to
optimize
and you don't always want to optimize
the same things in all the projects
okay so the best is a very heavy loaded
word
it depends on what you want
so what's really important i think is
that to have a conscious to have
knowledge about all these different ways
of thinking about problems once you have
that vocabulary that very large
vocabulary then you are free to kind of
go you know oh
that thing is good that thing is good
that thing is good and then you can just
you know then you're singing basically
then you're a master
okay so the question is how do you teach
this it's just too much
right it's just too much information uh
you could you could teach it by
let's speak languages that provide some
of these styles you know
speak java speak scheme prologue
you know haskell you know it's just too
much and what happens is that students
get stuck with syntax quite
a lot you know they just cannot go
through the synthetic sugar right there
it's just like a barrier
so in in kind of trying to figure out
how to teach
style um let's see if this one shows a
little better
please stick i came across this
author he's a french writer ramon keno
he lived in the sort of first half of
the
of the 20th century and um it's quite an
interesting guy you know
to go in and find weird things you
probably want to look into the
intellectuals
the french intellectuals of of the 20th
century they are really cool
so this guy's maybe a club
a workshop called uh um
the the workshop of something like
alternate
literature or something like that
translated into english it was a
a group of intellectual french
intellectuals in paris uh
writers mathematicians a lot of
mathematicians
um and so their whole thing their whole
motto was constraints
so they gave themselves constraints to
do work
okay so they give constraints to write a
book or constraints to
you know to do a painting and these
constraints sometimes
uh work just on the form so things like
for example
i don't know if you are aware one of the
guys who was part of this club was one
an author that wrote the book uh
translated to english is called a void
who knows a void not many people it's an
interesting
book so the entire book is a perfectly
normal
book normal it's interesting the story
is interesting but what makes it really
interesting is that the entire book
does not have a single occurrence of the
letter e
now you're trying to write a book
without the letter e
okay it's it's a very simple constraint
but it immediately has some
huge implications on for example the
choice of words right
it's you kind of have to scratch your
head oh wait i cannot use that word
because it
doesn't eat it okay so it produces a
kind of an interesting uh
you know uh effects so so they gave
themselves the idea of
styles as constraints and um one thing
that this guy wrote was a book
i again i recommend that you look it up
and maybe even buy it
it's called exercises in style and it's
exactly that exercises
for the writer for the aspiring writer
and
what the book does is you take a story
you know completely stupid dumb story
that can be told in like 30 seconds
um and uh
he wrote it in 99 different ways okay
there's things like um metaphors
surprises prognostication hesitation
precision
negativities and you also have like
mathematical constraints like
the words have to have you know n
characters or something like that you
know
because arbitrary constraints like that
so i read that already spoken i thought
oh this is a great way of teaching
people styles
right let me do exactly let me copy this
i'm just going to copy this it's a great
idea
so uh so what i wanted to do is do
exactly the same thing for programming
so exercises in programming style take a
a
very simple problem and the problem that
i chose is term frequency
and here's the story given a text file
output a list of the 25 most frequently
occurring words
ordered by decreasing frequency
everybody here knows how to do this
right
question is whether you can do this in
five minutes or in half an hour
right so everybody knows how to do this
super easy so
if you have something like you feed it
pride and prejudice one of my
favorite books to to term frequency and
you
output a list of you know something like
that
with elizabeth being one of the most
frequently occurring words
uh all right so um let me get going and
this is the part where i could be here
for a long time
so i have nine styles here and
i want your cooperation um
the the the last time that i gave this
talk to a group of programming language
experts i got in a lot of trouble and
the reason why i got into a lot of
trouble is that i decided to name the
styles myself
and as you know naming is one of the
hardest things in computer science right
so i get that my choice of names was
highly contested by this group of
experts so i will not do the same
mistake twice
and in this talk i will just give them
numbers that's what you do when you
don't know what to name your variables
right
so but i want your collaboration
and if you are connected you can do it
right now if you're not connect you can
do it later
please tweet me what you think the
styles should be called
now i i have my own names for this talk
and they are just fun names okay maybe i
even use these names when i teach
the students but some of these names
some of these styles really capture
concepts that have been around forever
and that i believe there are certain
words technical words technical terms
that people
have been using that associates to those
styles but i am not going to do that
mistake again
so you please tell me what you think the
technical term should be for each of
these styles okay
so here we go style number one
let's see if if this wants to
collaborate this isn't just a pager code
and i don't expect you to screen to be
able to read i just i'm going to
to highlight certain parts of it but
just for the layout
you can have a feel for what's going on
in here okay
one page of code with lots of
indentations nested
lexical scopes okay so let me sort of
highlight some of the things that are
going on in here one
is on the top i have sort of global
variables over there so i have a word
frequency
list that's going to end up having the
word you know
counting the words and then i open the
stop words
because when you do term frequency you
want to eliminate stop words you know
the words that occur very frequently
right so i
i open i and i um i just construct my
stop words list over there
and then from then on i basically have
two nasty loops one that iterates
through the lines of the file i read one
line at the file
at the time from the file and the other
one that goes through the characters one
character at a time
okay and and you can guess what's in
that
part of the code right i need to detect
the beginning of a word the end of a
word
uh then i need to once i detect the word
i need to figure out whether it's a stop
word and then i have to implement the
count
okay that's sort of what's going on in
here
okay so what are the main
characteristics of this style
one characteristics that there are no
abstractions okay
it's just this one thing i just wrote
the whole thing
okay i didn't even stop to think what
was i doing behind each line i just
wrote the whole thing
another characteristic is that it's it
it results in very heavy control flow so
you see that in the nested
indentations right there's that there
are ifs and
elves and elsies and breaks and things
like that that
that come up um in in this kind of style
now
how many of you have seen code written
in this style
okay so i can say with 100 certainty
that 100 of you have seen code written
new stuff
how many of you have written code in
this style
okay so you know what i'm talking about
yeah
we've all seen this okay now when we
teach
uh students we we always tell them don't
do this
right and it's a good advice
try not to do it but sometimes you just
gotta do it right
it's just you don't have time or
whatever so
please tell me tweet me the name of what
you think this
uh style should be called okay i have
here's my fun
name okay brain
dump style he's just like boo
all right style number two
you ready style number two that's it
okay so this is so small that i can
actually expand it all and explain one
line at a time it's actually just five
lines of code
okay so here's what's going on first i'm
constructing the stop
list the support list over there with i
open the file i read it and split it and
add the list of of lowercase letters
okay then i also construct the words
by reading the file there's the read
file over there
then i uh i do a regular expression
check just to filter out the
ascii you know a to z characters i
eliminate the other ones
um i i lowercase them
um and if they're not in the stop words
and you know whatever goes through that
filter ends up in the list of words
right uh next one i'm actually going to
do the unique words because there are
many repetitions on that list of words
right
so i'm going to just say um the set
of words and the set in python just
makes you you makes it unique right so
now i have unique words and then i have
this funny line over here
um which sorts
the unique words using a lambda function
over there
that's that's the comparator over here
the the the sorter function
okay how do i start i test whether the
count of one
is greater than the count of the other
okay i guess that many of you are
already scratching their heads ah
why what's going on yeah okay yeah
that's one of the one of the
characteristics of this style
um and then i print it out and then i
print it out so that's that's it
so so it turns out that uh that this is
an interesting style i
actually should be credited to laurie
tratt he's a
a person that i meet in some research
conferences he
gave me this for fun um
so there's a funny thing here that this
is really short right it's very very
short each of these lines is
full of stuff it's doing a lot right
trying really hard and it's just it so
happens that if you if you run this on
private prejudice
it takes about four minutes to run
on the fast desktop computer so
what is going on well you know what that
thing over there is really
really really bad okay every time that
you want to find the count of a word
you're actually computing it okay you
you're computing it the words you're
counting them
every time that you need the count
you're counting them over you know
it's really really bad and you make
these comparisons you know
lots and lots of times so so so yes
short great uh
three minutes bad so it turns out that
there's a there's a variation in this if
you add two more lines of code
you make it efficient again okay now
leave it as an exercise
um the other thing is that this is not
completely right and this this program
actually has a little bug that many of
you may not even notice
and it will show up only if you maybe
run this in a server that would be very
heavy hit very heavy okay
and only in certain python runtimes and
not others
so what's going on there is that you're
opening files and not closing them
okay and so in some python runtimes uh
the the python interpreter compiler does
the right thing on the on
when you have a a list comprehension in
other in other cases it doesn't
so it keeps the files open so it might
eventually run out of
file descriptors so it's one of those
bugs that it never shows
unless you have it in sort of a high-end
production
any anyway so here's the the the style
main characteristics there are no named
abstractions here because you know
abstraction takes too many lines of code
you know you don't want to define a
function because that's yeah one more
line of code
so so uh there are very few long lines
of code
full of meaning that you kind of have to
wrap your head around
what is going on in there and uh and
also there's
that tends to be comes coupled with the
the the will or the wish
to use advanced libraries and everything
that's advanced in the the programming
language right
there's always that person in your
project that wants to use the
third that third-party library because
you know
instead of 20 lines of code you write
just two
right and then you introduce another
dependency in your project
so so so um i want a name for this
please
for this style tell me the name of this
style
all right so here's my i have two fun
names for this one this one can be
code golf style do you know code golf
code
cold golf is a whole genre of activities
out there on the internet
that consists in trying to code
something in as few lines of code as
possible
okay so that's one that's one name the
other name might be
try hard style
all right style number three
this one has a page and a half
and uh let me tell you what's going on
in this in this in this program over
here so
one thing let me start sort of by the
main function as usual the main function
is a good
indicator of what's going on so there's
the mind function and in the main
function
i'm just issuing these commands
okay read the file filter normalize scan
remove the stop words count the
frequencies sort and then
paint it out at the end and so what i
have over here i i'm defining these
abstractions
okay these procedures are procedural
abstractions
and each one is meant to do one step of
the problem okay
so i've divided the problem into smaller
problems and for each of the smaller
problems i'm giving it a procedural
abstraction
and um in this particular case i have
also global variables over there and you
see if you see over here you don't see
data
the data is magically changed in the
procedures
and it's shared by the procedures and
you end up with something that looks
like a
you know an instruction do this do that
and stuff happens in the space in the
shared uh
state that you have okay so
everybody knows this style yes yeah this
is one of the most basic styles
of programming
um so what is the what what are the
characteristics of this style well we
have now procedural abstractions what
are procedures well procedures are these
units
that you give them a name they may take
input
they may produce output but it's not
necessarily relevant to the
to the you know the thing that they are
doing maybe an error code for example
that they return
uh they just do something it's an
abstraction of a piece of code
um they may have shared states
in this style you usually have shared
state among the procedures and then you
have this command so
you basically solve the big problem by
decomposing it into smaller
procedures and then calling one
procedure at a time
okay so i think everybody probably will
converge on the name of this style
all right let me give it a fun name
cookbook style
okay this is typically what you find in
cookbooks
okay you're mixing the eggs with the
butter
leave it there do something else over
here mix something else and then at some
point mix everything together
and you're done all right style number
four here we go so style number four is
actually very similar to style number
three
so let me show you what's inside um
so i also divide my problem into smaller
problems and i abstract them
now the kinds of abstractions that i
give to my to my uh
problem are not just procedures they're
actually
functions okay so i divide my problem as
a series of functions and what what are
functions what's the difference between
functions and procedures well functions
are
relations from inputs to outputs that's
what you learn in mathematics right
that's what a function is forget about
computer science
okay you have a relation set of inputs
maps
to a set of outputs that's what a
function is so that there it is so i
i in all of these abstractions that i
have here
i they receive input and they return
something
right they all return something and so
what i do
in my main function the way that i solve
the problem is by
giving the output of one of these
functions
as the input to the next okay
it's and sorry i had to change the names
of the functions over there otherwise it
wouldn't fit
okay but they refer to these over here
but basically you just
chain all these things and you write
because it's mathematics and comes from
algebra
which it comes from arabic it goes from
right to left
right is just like not left to right so
you start over there
okay so this is this you probably also
know what the technical term of this
style might be
but here are the main characteristics uh
you divide the problem into function
abstractions
right and functions are the mathematical
functions that map inputs to outputs
that's it that's your constraints
okay there's no shared states there was
no state in here so
all the state all the data that's going
on is being uh
uh weaved through you know as the output
of one function to the input to the next
okay nothing persists in the world
there's nothing but that
pipeline okay and you compose the the
you you solve the big problem by by
doing mathematical function composition
f after g that's your style right there
so
i'm sure that you probably know the name
of this style i'll i'll be happy to kind
of
entertain other more you know different
names so here's here's the fun name that
i give it the
charlie and the chocolate factory style
okay that's you have you have this
pipeline right each of these functions
just
gets an input receives an output and
change it to the other one
and uh and and this style is great
because you know one thing that you can
also do you can sort of wrap this
this little two boxes in just a w as an
input
to another box right and you have these
higher order
little pieces of pipeline which is
really nice it's a nice model right
so uh the pipeline or the chocolate
factory style
okay style number five here we go
um okay so what is going on in this one
let me show you what's going on in this
one the abstractions are this similar
very similar so we have
we have functions too we have functions
that receive something and return
something else
but now what they are returning they are
to return not just the value but they
are returning
the result of calling a function and
that was the function that we
actually sent as a parameter so in this
style the constraint is that there's
always one extra parameter that's
supposed to be a function
and that's supposed to be called at the
very end
okay who has seen this style
okay styling has been around for a while
uh
it's made popular now with javascript uh
but has been around for a while
and and so what you what the beginning
over there is that you you call sort of
the first function
and you give it the next okay and you
chain these functions like that
you know you just chain them okay
so so functions take one additional
parameters there's your constraint
okay f that if that that parameter is
called at the end
and uh and it it's it's given what you
would normally be
return the return value plus the next
function
i need a name for this please i'm sure
that you will converge
also here um
crochet style i don't know whenever i
see this style the first thing that
comes to mind is crochet
because you have this loop you go get
the next you know the next thing
okay and you i always feel like pulling
the thread at some point is just
and do the whole thing that'd be fine
so that's that's my that's my uh
metaphor that comes to miley's
crochet style all right style number six
here we go
it's a little bigger a little more
verbose and so let me
tell you what's going on in this in this
style so this style so in the previous
styles we either didn't have any
obstructions
or we had these procedures right these
actions that we want to do
some or there might might actually be
functions right
so in this style we don't have any of
that okay so the way that we want to
think about the problem
is like this forget about the functions
and everything what we really want to
think about
the problem is indeed seeing these
things in the world
okay there are things in the world and
things relate to each other because they
do similar things okay so
for the term frequency we end up with
something like well we have a data
storage manager right
that's the thing that's going to take
care of
dealing with the file and splitting the
words and stuff that's the data right so
we have data storage manager
we also need to count the frequency so
we have like a free
the the word frequency manager if you
want you know it's supposed to
count things we have also the word stop
word manager because we have to worry
about stop words so we have
a manager there too um and then we have
sort of the controllers like
the main thing the main entity that
starts it all right and we
and and so each of these each of these
entities each of these things is
is a thing that does actions and the
actions are sort of defined inside
itself
here are some of the actions that the
data storage manager
does and that are publicly visible to
the outside
there are many things that not publicly
visible to outside in fact
one of the things of this way of
thinking about the problem is that we
never
interact with data directly okay we
interact with these
entities that wrap the data and we
interact with them by calling
their procedures that they decide to
advertise to the world
okay so
another thing that these entities also
can do that came with this style
whenever people were thinking about this
style is that and the entities can say
oh you know what i can do everything
that that entity can do
and more okay why not
okay so i you know i can say i can do
everything that my mom can do
maybe not i definitely cannot cook like
her
so so you have this this notion of the
entities
declaring that they are or they they can
do the same things
as other entities which turn out to be a
very interesting mechanism in in
programming because it allows you
a certain flavor of code reuse
that you model your world as these
entities and then you know
what if you have a parent entity then
the children entities
inherit all of that stuff that the
parent entity uh
knew how to do okay so here are the main
characteristics there things things
things and more things
okay you just you you designed the
problem
by first modeling it in terms of things
okay and then what is it that those
things do those are the procedures
inside those things
so there are capsules of data and
procedures and then the data is never
accessed directly and the capsules can
say i do the same things
as that other one and more okay so this
one style i am sure that you will also
all converge to
who has done code in this style
yes okay so i i'm sure that you all
converge to a name
i'll call it the kingdom of noun style
oh the info method is just to illustrate
that i can do
the same that that other thing okay so
the question is what was this info
method i had this info method all over
that's because i had a thing over there
called tf exercise
that has absolutely no other purpose
than to illustrate the mechanism of
things saying i can do that okay and
that
in python is done with this syntax that
you you give it an argument
okay
oh wow okay all right well somebody's
flagging me
so i let me let me jump to as i said
this this is a flexible talk i can go on
it can go from
10 minutes to to six hours
so let me let me go here to one of the
interesting styles
so um here's style number eight
okay this one is really really different
so in the previous styles you thought
about modeling the problem
in different abstractions but basically
it was all they were all doing the same
thing
okay this style actually doing something
different
okay whoever came up with this style is
really thinking
outside of the box so to speak okay it's
really different
so in this style let me show you first
the main which is down there
okay i'm going to explode it here and
here's what what
what is what whoever thought about this
file really think okay so i have this
file okay
private and prejudice has many many
lines of text
so what i really want to do is to be
able to process things in parallel
right count things in parallel that can
be done i just chunk the file
okay and then i process each chunk in
parallel that's going to be faster right
and then i and then i have to count
because the words occur in different
chunks
so i need to some somehow uh converge
and and uh accumulate the counters for
all these different chunks
okay so so here's the main i i i call
the map function that takes a function
split words
on on a bunch of chunks i partition my
file into 200 chunks over there
okay um
then i do a little sort of massage here
into the splits
bring preparation for the reduce okay
then i reduce
the reduce give it another function
count words this is what i want to do
when i reduce
right i cut two words on my split and
then
i i spit it out okay so what
is the what everybody probably knows
what that's a please sleep words i don't
have time to go through it
and and the count words i also have time
so the main characteristics of this were
there two key abstractions
there's the map of a function two chunks
that it means apply that function to
each of these chunks
potentially in parallel and then there's
the reduce
so here's a bunch of results okay a list
of results and i'll
reduce them by applying that function
over there
all right so everybody knows what the
name of this style is right
um it's imute i mute i i multiplexer the
inverse multiplexer style
if you have a background in electronics
so these ideas have all been around in
you know lots of different places
they're not
super new all right so
um i had another style that's also
completely different
but i i guess i'm running out of time
so um let me just uh jump to the end of
the talk
um i'm actually writing a book about
this which is
geared to be sort of a fun upper
undergraduate
young graduates at that level over there
when people know enough
to be dangerous but may have not been
you know
may have not thought about the all of
these different ways of solving the
problem and what they're going to
encounter when they go out into the
world
um the code will hit github
as soon as i figure out what i should
call these styles
right now what's hanging me is that i
don't know what to call them and and
if i choose the right names i know that
i'm going to be you know
basically shot so uh as soon as i decide
what i should be calling these styles i
will put all the code in github and now
i
i welcome uh variations of in style that
you have seen faction i have the book
is uh my goal is to have 33 different
styles and i could go on forever but
33 seems like a good reasonable number
for me to actually finish writing the
book
okay and it will hit the the bookstores
in in the spring of 14
hopefully thank you